all right a great great pleasure to have
mark zuckee
uh from stanford uh mark take take it
away
okay um
so thanks very much for the invitation
uh so i'll talk about multiplayer
bandits without communication
um i'll mention two uh works i was
involved in one of which was with
sebastian and tamar the other was
of which was with alan
um but i'll take a little bit to get
there i'll start by first setting up
what is multiplayer bandits and then
i'll really talk for a bit about
communication and uh why it is an
important uh key careful uh track of
when studying this problem
and
then in the second half i'll say a bit
about how you can get square to regret
and even some
gap dependent regret bounds
for this problem in a pretty strong
sense with kind of no communication no
collisions
okay so
let's start so we all know the standard
stochastic bandit problem
uh we have some finite set of actions
each one has some reward probability
we don't know what the reward
probabilities are and we want to get as
much reward as possible over time
and
usually what we keep track of is the
regret so this is the um
the difference between the total reward
from the best arm
and the total reward that we end up
collecting ourselves
and there's kind of two
different types of regret bounds that
one kind of typically looks at
so the first main one that you'd look at
is getting square root t regret so here
you don't care what the probability
of reward free charm is at all and this
bound you just want square t no matter
what
and then maybe the second thing you look
at
is getting a gap dependent bound so
you want your regret to scale like log t
over delta where delta is the gap
between the best and second best r
okay so these are kind of the things
we'll be interested in looking at in a
multiplayer setting
how is multiplayers gonna work well
we're gonna have multiple players i'll
call them x and y you can often just
think about two players in fact
and uh
the interesting thing is that the
players are trying not to collide on the
same arm so if you and i are playing and
we pick the same arm at the same time
that's a collision that's very bad
neither of us gets a reward
and i'll say a bit more about exactly
like there's some there's some choice in
deciding exactly how bad it is but
somehow it's a bad thing
and we're going to be in a full
cooperation setting so there's no game
theory there's no incentives there's no
nash equilibrium
and so we have a very simple to state
benchmark we're just trying to collect
as much reward as possible
so the kind of optimum thing to do would
be one of us
just goes on the best arm every time the
other of us gets on the second best arm
every time
and so that's kind of our regret
benchmark
so this model was proposed for
uh wireless radio communications so it
is maybe i want to pick a good frequency
you want to pick a good frequency but we
don't interfere with each other
and
if we can kind of
work together throughout this process
then this is just a semi-bandit problem
uh so instead of picking one arm every
time step we pick maybe two arms every
time step we try to get the best pair of
arms
uh
this is you know there's online shortest
path is some variation of this
but we're going to be aiming for a
distributed algorithm where we cannot
communicate with each other
so somehow we have to come up with some
protocol beforehand so that one of us
ends up on the top arm the other one of
us ends up on the second best arm and
and we somehow don't synchronize or talk
to each other at all in doing
this okay
now there's a lot of possibilities for
algorithms uh in a sense the
central difficulty is that it's hard to
break ties so we could say that i'm
gonna try to get the second best arm
you're gonna try to get the best arm but
okay maybe they're very close together
how can we
you know we're gonna we have noisy
measurements we don't see exactly the
same feedback like what do we how do we
figure this out
and
if we can detect collisions this helps a
lot
um that's kind of the the first thing
you might uh think of trying to do here
uh because if i can tell when we collide
then then we can communicate with each
other
so uh this was observed for instance in
this paper by a later levian cross uh so
they showed this uh pretty simple
algorithm to get t to the two-thirds
regret uh if you can detect collisions
so here's what you're gonna do you're
gonna break your t time steps into
blocks of length cube root of t
within each block everyone's going to do
the same thing until the next block
but in between blocks we're going to
spend just a little bit of time like log
t times synchronizing with each other
we'll just communicate a little bit
using these collisions as ways to send
bits and we'll sync up all our
information and this just reduces to a
semi-banded game
and
you get key to the two-thirds regret by
just doing this reduction
okay but this isn't really a distributed
algorithm uh
i mean somehow the communication via
collisions is maybe too powerful
at the end of the day what is
not in communication but we have
deductible collisions well how we learn
that we have detectable collisions since
we do not communicate
sorry can you repeat that
you say that we do not communicate
but
on the other hand we have
the ability to detect collisions so
who tells us that the system who
how we learn that
uh
right so
so i guess the the question is about the
difference between
like what do i mean when i say there's
no communication
yes
yeah right exactly so so kind of
if communication is really for free you
know i'm kind of saying communication
isn't really for free but yes yes
totally you know this is basically
communication it's just the hack to get
around it so what i'm what i'm trying to
go through is kind of uh
how we can eventually get to a problem
set up where there's really no
communication so this so i'm kind of
treating this as a bad problem set up um
because
you it kind of you can embed
communication inside it
uh so i hope that
so i think it was just a basic question
about like the feedback model and just
because the feedback model is
you know everyone plays their arms and
gets their you know sees their own
rewards and sees a bit that says whether
or not there was a collision when you
and that that's what the detectable
collision model is right
uh yeah yeah exactly
yeah yeah so so at you know if i collide
then then i see not only that i received
zero reward i i get told you know you
got the reward because there was a
collision
yeah
it's kind of very explicit
thanks
yeah thanks i
should have been more clear about that
uh
yeah so it so not surprisingly if you
get this explicit feedback about
collisions you can do a lot um in fact
you can even get square to regret with
adversarial rewards by doing a more
complicated version of this idea
okay
um so the takeaway i want to
kind of get from this is that we should
set up the problem better to not allow
communication
so let's try to do that
uh so we'll
uh
so here's here's my setup i'm going to
have my unknown reward probability
vector
uh i'm going to have
independent for newly reward variables
for for any arm and every time even
every player
and
at any time if a player x chooses an arm
itx
they receive a reward which is given by
the underlying bernoulli random variable
uh times zero if there was a collision
so if it's time zero if he collided with
someone else
uh so that's the reward you got and you
do not get to observe whether a
collision occurs
and like i mentioned before the regret
is kind of the difference between the
total reward accumulated by all the
players together
and the sum of the best m arms okay
maybe surprisingly um there's still a
choice to be made about how to set up
the problem
because
um
i haven't told you what feedback is
actually received
so here are two um very natural models
the collisions can either be weakly
detectable or undetected
so if the collisions are weakly
detectable
i'm going to say that means we
actually observe the reward that we
receive so if i collide
i'm gonna receive zero award
and i'm gonna
be told that i got zero awards so the
collision affects my feedback so i don't
get told why i got zero reward i don't
get told the collision happened but i
see
i see the zero
but i could also have undetectable
collisions maybe the the collision
messes something up uh further down in
the pipeline and i don't actually see it
i just see the reward i would have
gotten otherwise
okay
so we have these two models um
you know are they equivalent is one
harder than the other
how do they compare to maybe a less
clean collision model where the behavior
of collisions is
is more arbitrary does either one of
them lead me to have to think about
decentralized algorithms
uh
so you know a lot of questions uh here
are some answers
that i'll explain in more detail in the
rest of the talk
so first off if you want to get square
root t regret you can still do it in
either case
um but you can get much better gap
dependent guarantees if you have weak
detectability so if your reward is zero
when you collide and you you get to see
that your reward is zero then you can
get one over the gap up to log t factors
and stuff
but um
if you don't if collisions are totally
undetectable they don't affect your
feedback at all
then the gap dependence behavior gets a
lot more complicated and there's a whole
range of pareto optima
gap dependence curves
ranging between square root t and one
over the gap squared mark
let me ask you again so
what does it mean now the feedback that
you get
i mean you say
collisions affect the rewards do the
players see the rewards or no
right so so in the in the first model uh
which is labeled a here you your
feedback is exactly the reward that you
receive
so it if there's a collision then you
observe
the zero
in the second one
and the second one you
you observe the bernoulli variable that
corresponds to the reward you would get
assuming there's no collision
so if there's a collision then you don't
observe it you just you think you got a
reward but you actually didn't
yeah
so
like
one way one reason this is something
that's good to think about is that um
here there's really no way to
communicate at all like you just
your
your feedback is totally independent of
what anyone else does
um in the second in the in the first
case in the weekly detectable case
there's still some potential to transfer
information between players
yeah
does that answer your question
yeah yeah it's fine
awesome yeah thanks
um okay so i'll keep going um
so in this uh case of undetectable
collisions um the gap dependence gets
more complicated and
um the optimal guarantees are actually
sorry
yeah
sorry quick question while we're playing
with the model um
we consider the case where
if there's a collision the adversary is
allowed to know you picked it and give
you whatever reward it wants to mess up
your algorithm
yeah
but you haven't considered that kids
uh yeah so um
so
uh i'll say in a moment um the
undetectable case is the hardest case
and it's it's solved by cl by algorithms
that just never collide at all so like
the algorithms i'll actually talk about
will just have no collisions at all so
they'll also solve the case you proposed
great thank you yeah
yeah so that yeah that's exactly like
the kind of thing that you might have in
mind you know you can have a malicious
adversary
that
does something really weird when there's
a collision um
and if you have an algorithm that never
collides at all then you solve that case
also
um but it's maybe surprising that um
just saying that collisions don't affect
your feedback is just as hard in terms
of the like optimal regret bounce
um yeah so that that's kind of what i
was
getting into so so if you just care
about mini max regret then any feedback
model you get square root t
but if you care about gap dependence
then
weakly detectable
is easiest so when you see the actual
reward you got uh the gap dependence is
the same as in the standard one player
bandit
um
if you
um
on the other hand
the the worst case for gap dependence uh
is obtained by collision-free algorithms
and it also is kind of witnessed by the
undetectable collision case
yeah and and the nice thing about
collision free again is that it solves
any case of the problem even if there's
an adversary
any more questions about this stuff
um this is a good part to ask questions
about probably
okay great um yeah keep asking questions
uh but but i'll keep going if there
aren't any
uh so let me first uh spend just a
little bit saying what happens when
they're weakly detectable collisions so
so when you you observe zero when
there's a collision so this was an idea
from uh this nice paper of huang cones
and tren and there was a later work with
some similar conclusions as well
so the first step is that the players
somehow agree on a decent arm so maybe
it's not so easy to agree on the best
arm but somehow they managed to
synchronize on a decent arm that's you
know within a constant factor of the
best reward probably
and then they're gonna use this arm as a
gadget for communication so they're
again gonna take even this uh
weaker amount of detectability and turn
it into communication
and the way it's going to work is kind
of if i want to communicate i'll play
this special arm for a while
and i'll play it for long enough so that
if i receive no reward while i was
playing it i know someone else was also
playing
like in this first phase i have some
decent amount of
i have some decent estimate of its
reward probability pj i know that if i
play it for a lot more than one over pj
time it's not it should give me
so if it doesn't give me reward i know
someone else is kind of on the other
side of the wall trying to talk to me
also
so
so if i don't see any reward and then we
try to talk to each other and we just do
this by exchanging bits using
again just like blocks of time when
there's no reward on this arc
so somehow you can implement this
and
the the nice thing is that there's some
cancellation so
because the arm is close to the best arm
the
the regret from
doing
this communication procedure is not too
high
if the word probability pj is small
so
uh
there's kind of this cancellation so
even if it takes a long time to to send
a bit like one over pj time the the
regret of this communication is just
like basically one per bit we send
so
as a result you we kind of can build
this communication protocol that
works very well regret wise and we can
just do whatever
so i i mean i think this is very nice
in fact you don't even need to have like
zero reward as long as the mean reward
is a little bit lower than the uh
non-collision reward then you know you
can detect this kind of thing
but you know it's still communication
so so what i'll focus on for the second
half is um
algorithms that really have no
communication
and
um and as i've been saying this this
means that there's not only no
communication but there's there's no
collisions at all so they work in any
one
so the main result on mini max regret is
with uh sebastian and tamah
and we showed is that you can get regret
square root t log t times some poly
factors in the number of actions
and the probability that there's ever a
collision is something like o of t to
the minus two you can make that minus
two minus a hundred it's all three
uh
in fact the log is real um so even with
full feedback
uh
the the log t is is really there which
is a little surprising because it's not
true in the single player case and um
here there's a specific definition of
full feedback i'm using i'm saying all
the rewards are independent so even if i
if you and i both try the same arm at
the same time
in full feedback we'll see different
things like like the the arm will give
rewards diff independently to different
players
um that's kind of a nice full feedback
model here because it prevents any
shared information
uh so to see how this works uh let me
first explain kind of a topological
obstruction
uh in the case of two players in three
arms where we can draw a picture
so
so i'm gonna work in the case of three
arms and i'm going to work in the plane
capital p where the total reward
probability is a constant
and i'm going to work in a full feedback
and
because we're assuming some kind of
undetectability or no collisions um
the
the feedback the actions of one player
don't affect the feedback of the other
players at all
so if there's just two players
basically i just have pre-specified
functions so so you know at time 10
i will have pre-specified my function
which tells me you know if i saw this
amount of average reward from each of
the arms
so i have these
empirical estimates for each arm's
reward probability here's what i'm going
to i'm just going to have this function
ready in advance
uh the other player is going to have
this function ready in advance and we
just we need to design these functions
so that there aren't going to be
collisions
and if you try to do this naively
there's there's kind of an issue
um
so basically you can think that the two
players have
have um
empirical estimates of the true reward
vector p
and they're close to each other but
there's some noise of order one over
square root t
and
what you would try to do is always play
the top two actions so in this uh this
triangle is kind of the state space of
possible um
probability vectors so there's a corner
for one best two best three best and so
on
um
so
these these green uh regions are kind of
corresponding to a greedy strategy where
we're always playing the top two actions
according to our
uh estimates
but you get this topological obstruction
if you go in a circle kind of you can't
transition between one comma three and
three comma one uh without causing some
collisions to happen because if you just
if you just have a line separating one
comma three and three comma one that's
saying that
uh
like if if my estimate is in the one
comma three region and your estimate is
in the three comma one region then we're
gonna play the same action we're going
to collide
so so here these these pairs are kind of
like my action comma your action
so
if i'm in 1-3 and you're in 1-2 then
that's fine there's no collision but if
i'm in 1-3 and you're in 3-1 then maybe
we both play action one
um
is the does the picture make sense or
should i say more about what this means
sorry what is the cumulative uh loss
from
colliding sometimes
um so we're just going to try to not
collide at all basically so you can just
just understand your obstruction here i
mean
the point you're trying to make i mean
like
yeah sometimes uh our estimates are
gonna be off and we're gonna disagree
but eventually hopefully we're gonna
resolve i mean
how like
if you try to aggregate the laws coming
from this uh you know large deviation
bounds but like how bad is it i mean is
it root t or is it like uh it can kill
you and
yeah
um
so
so you're thinking of collisions are
like really undetectable
uh
i'm not talking about collisions i'm
talking about estimates for the rewards
of the arms so
yeah i understand that the p hats are
different from the real ps
and maybe we have i think it's one three
you think i mean i think the top is one
you think the top is three and you know
like but okay like say when this happens
like in the rounds this happens we
collide
uh you know okay so we both receive
further information so which makes our p
hat better
and you know are we gonna are we gonna
get out of this uh problem or not i mean
that's i guess the question
or like if i were to add a little bit
exploration around you know whatever
like my uncertainty or something
collect more data maybe you know and so
forth mix it up
like can i get out of this uh
rabbit hole or is it surprise like
so so i think if the
um if if you're really in this
undetectable model like it it's possible
for it to be okay i think um but like in
in most cases when you're thinking about
this problem like you know there's
there's some
you know
like if your feedback gets corrupted
when you collide then you just can't
really start analyzing what happens with
a small number of collisions like you're
just you're just going to be way off
forever in the future
oh i see yeah yeah i was talking about
the undetectable yeah yeah that's right
yeah
yeah
yeah
um
i think it with undetectable it it may
be kind of okay to kind of close your
eyes and just
just do something uh simple here
um but
i i think it's really a better guarantee
to try to avoid collisions entirely
yeah yeah thank you
so
so here's what you can do to avoid
collisions um so this is an idea of
sebastian
what you do is you um you break this
topological obstruction by putting some
padding here so that's shown in orange
so we're going to intentionally play
this bad action 2
when our estimates
of p are in this padding
so this is going to have a small chance
of making us i mean it's going to
sometimes make us make bad decisions but
it's going to prevent collisions because
uh we just have to make the padding wide
enough so that we're never on opposite
sides of the pack
okay
and
uh
if you kind of put the orange padding
layer in a random location like you give
it a random angle then on average you're
gonna hurt any given problem instance a
small amount
you're kind of spreading out the extra
regret
and outside the padding you can just be
greedy so you can get square to regret
um another thing is that everything like
these pictures you can kind of think of
things as full feedback but um things
become a lot harder if you have bandit
feedback so like it turns out you can
turn this picture into an algorithm but
um
yeah if you uh
if you come up with some other way to do
this it might be hard to turn it into a
banded feedback algorithm
i won't say too much about that part
um
so kind of the the first thing is that
well
how does this picture work in higher
dimensions you know if i have a
k-dimensional simplex or something
what are we going to do
so we came up with a more general
partition that extends to fully general
numbers of players in number of arms
here's what it looks like in the same
two-player three-action case
it's kind of a tree so you can think
that the orange region is the root of
some tree
and
kind of
the purple and the light green are its
children and the
the dark green or the children of the
and these regions are formed by arm
inequalities added in order so
at the root um the label is kind of just
one two three with no inequalities so we
have our three actions when and we
haven't made any decisions about which
ones are better than which others
but in for example these light green
regions uh were we have some
inequalities like in the bottom one the
inequality is that two and three are
both bigger than one so that's telling
me that actions two and three are better
than action one
and
once we add more inequalities we're also
going to keep track of the order in
which we added them so
in in kind of
more generality for a bigger picture you
could have this um
thing with three inequalities i have on
the bottom here 1 3 5 is bigger than 4 8
is bigger than 2 6 is bigger than 7 9 10
and we're keeping track of the order we
add these inequalities which allows us
to get some tree structure
so
the idea is that these orange and also
purple regions are serving a similar
role of padding to kind of separate out
the main part of the diagram which are
these green regions and the orange and
purple are in random locations
so there's kind of a
general nice way to think about this
less pictorially
first off you never compute with the
full tree so there's a huge number of
regions but you can just take in an
empirical alarm estimate
an empirical estimate of the probability
vector and output
the what the partition tells you to do
efficiently
and
the way that this works is that you
start with just all the arms and you
don't know anything about the relative
order and you repeatedly try to kind of
add new inequalities
to separate arms that might be in the
top end
and once the top m and the bottom k
minus m are determined then you stop
adding inequalities you've kind of found
a leaf in the partition tree
so here you we start with all ten
actions we're trying to find the top
five
so we first add this inequality that
breaks off the best seven versus the
bottom three so now we know that the
bottom three are not relevant anymore
but all of the top seven are still
relevant
then we break off the top three so those
guys are no longer relevant because
they're definitely in the top five that
we're aiming for but there's this middle
uh group of four where we need to pick
out the best two
so once we do that then we're done
we've found a leaf in our partition tree
and we'll have some precomputed label
that tells each player what to do
and
we'll decide whether to add these
inequalities based on some uh
random thresholds we've picked before so
there's a lot of shared randomness used
here just beforehand to to compute
to prescribe how to compute these
partition trees
um and the padding layer comes when
you're very close to adding the
inequality or not
okay
um now in this construction if we turn
to looking at gap dependent regret which
is the last thing i'm hoping to talk
about
um
the square root t additional regret from
the random padding
applies for all the gaps
so you really get square root t for
anything
um
this is not so great
so if we want to improve things for
large gaps we should kind of push the
padding away
uh and
here's here's how we did this so this is
with alan
um
we designated the problem instances with
a large gap larger than some threshold
delta one has safe zones
so they kind of don't have any padding
so these are these blue triangular
regions these turn out to be the regions
with very large
gaps in this
case
and we do the same
padding tree construction but if the
padding tries to enter these safe zones
it just kind of doesn't enter them it
kind of
bounces off the side is what the picture
ends up looking like
so if you have a problem instance with a
large gap bigger than this delta one so
you're kind of well inside this safe
zone
then
before too long
everyone's estimates will be well inside
the safe zone no padding will get
involved you have zero regret from that
point on so you're you're doing much
better
for
problem instances with a high gap
on the other hand this has a cost
it it makes things worse uh when you
don't have such a large gap
and the reason is that the padding
location becomes less random so before
these padding regions were just kind of
totally random they were kind of width
one over square root t they were totally
random so you had like a one over square
t probability to run into them which
adds up to root t
but now the
the padding
the the safe regions um
kind of restrict the possible locations
of the
the padding regions
by a factor of one over this delta one
so the result is you get a better
performance for large gaps but a worse
performance for small gaps there's this
uh trade-off here
and
this turns out to lead to the
best possible algorithms
for um
for the problem if there's
undetectable collisions and in fact it
it still works in a collision freeway
so more generally what you're going to
do is you're going to fix a sequence of
different gap sizes this is kind of a
schedule along which you're going to use
this kind of algorithm
and so after
you get to time bigger than delta j to
the minus two you you switch to that um
to that scale
and the result of this is
a regret guarantee
of at most one over delta i times delta
i plus one
for gaps that are bigger than than delta
i
uh and these are pareto optimal in the
sense that these are the best trade-off
curves up to poly k log t factors um so
if you want to get
better than one of these curves you have
to be worse somewhere else your regret
has to suffer somewhere else if you're
if you're better at some point
so this this has a lot of um nice
consequences and examples so
uh one example is if if you're um if
your gap size schedule delta i's are
going kind of slowly like by a constant
factor every time
then basically the regret is going to be
1 over the square of your gap
on the other hand if you just have like
delta 1 equals 1 and delta 2 equals t to
the minus one half so you have as little
going on as possible then you'll recover
the square root t regret
um
and so you can kind of say in several
sentences that square t is kind of
optimal and sort of a stable optimum so
so if your regret is less than t to the
point five one
uh then you cannot do better than square
root t regret for gaps that are
uh smaller than t to the minus point
zero one so there's there's some senses
in which you can you can say that you
know if your regret was good then it has
to suffer somewhere else
um let me just say a little bit briefly
about
how you prove this
the idea is some kind of topological
obstruction again
uh so you're gonna put a bunch of you're
gonna put square root t points kind of
uniformly around a circle and think of
adjacent pairs of points as plausible
pairs of like my
estimate comma your estimate
and there's some topological obstruction
saying that somewhere around the circle
there has to be a fail either there's a
collision or we play the bottom two out
of three actions
and by some kind of pigeonhole argument
this says that
you have a lot of fails
at some gap level
and this leads to some amount of regret
now this is just saying there exists
some gap with a lot of regret so how do
you get this lower bound with many gap
sizes
well the idea is to apply this lower
bound repeatedly
so maybe this lower bound
so there's this uh purple curve here
with regret square t over delta this
lower bound will tell tell me that my
regret curve has some point on this
purple
and
um once i have that i can say okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna look at only the the
first delta j to the minus two time
steps so now this this delta j point
that i found the red point on the curve
doesn't count as a large gap anymore
it's just one over square root t so now
i can kind of
apply the lower bound again on this
smaller time scale and get another
uh another lower bound point and if you
iterate this kind of lower bound
procedure you end up with the same um
credo optimum trade-off i should
uh okay let me just wrap up so maybe the
the main
takeaway of what i've said at a high
level is that if you're thinking about
multiplayer bandits the details of how
you set up
and think about collisions really matter
a lot
so if
if collisions are weakly detachable if
you get to see the zero reward then you
can still get the kind of best case
regret you can get both square root t
and you can get log t over delta
but uh if you can't detect collisions
then the regret gets much larger
at least for large gaps
and
these trade-offs are achieved with no
collisions at all so this is kind of
something that you can do
in any collision model
there are a lot of directions that
aren't so well understood uh adversarial
rewards are still uh posing some issues
uh you can make up all kinds of uh
more richer uh feedback structures uh
and you can uh think about what this
might have to say for rl
here's a picture of the
final algorithm and the pareto optimal
regret curves i discussed at the end
thanks very much and let me know if you
have any final questions
thank you very much mark this was fun uh
very interesting um
any questions in the room
uh so dylan
are you monitoring the chat
uh yeah there's no questions in the chat
right
now like i mean an obvious one maybe is
like you want to say a little bit about
the non-stochastic rewards
or what the challenges are there
[Music]
um
yeah i think it's just
quite a bit harder um
like
so so if collisions are detectable you
can or like like strongly detectable
like you're told whether you collide you
can get this square t algorithm
um
like
yeah i just don't know that much you can
do i think it's just very open so so we
had some algorithm where you run
learners that have like low swap regret
uh with kind of very different learning
rates and you can do something
so kind of if there's m players then you
get regret like t to the 1 minus 1 over
2m by
by kind of black box running a bunch of
learners with low swap regretted
different scales but you know t you know
an exponent of 1 minus 1 over 2m is
pretty bad
uh
interesting so even like t to the two
thirds or something is open
yeah i think that's right so
i i guess i've
i've like
people have like um
there have been some suggestions to try
to imitate the algorithms i was
discussing but
using some kind of like log barrier
mirror descent instead
um
like it seems like this might be
something that one can do but it seems
much more complicated um
i'm not sure
what the like i think there's nothing
like published on this i'm not sure if
the idea has like
gotten somewhere or what
cool thanks
that's a more general uh
feedback structures like for instance
maybe there's some subset of pairs of
arms such that if the agents take those
pairs they don't see
anything or you know
more general
more basically generalizations of
questions
yeah um yeah i think there's a lot of
open directions here and i think that's
a very interesting one that that's kind
of the sort of thing i was indicating
when i wrote network structure on this
slide actually just yeah
yeah you can also think you know arms
behave differently for different players
maybe there's some kind of coordination
game aspect
i think there are a lot of directions
here
all right so it's getting late let's
take further questions applied and thank
you again for the stuff thank you very
much
thanks a lot for having me
all right so see you tomorrow
and also like there is a